hey what's up cool cats oh my god we're
gonna like play truth or dab we are
about to play truth or dab i'm ben platt
by the way oh i'm a man listen break get
ready
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and welcome
back to another exciting episode of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last app and today i'm excited to
welcome amandla stemberg and ben platt
two of the stars of the sixth time tony
award-winning broadway musical turned
film dear evan hansen which is set to
release in theaters on september 24th
ben amandla welcome to the show thank
you so much thanks for having us we are
scared and excited to be here well let
me explain what's going on before we get
too deep into this so in front of you
guys have scorch not chicken wings that
have all been doused in various versions
of the last app i have a set of deeply
personal potentially awkward questions
for each of you and when i ask you a
question you have a choice answer it
honestly or escape the truth by eating a
deathwing
and amanda we'll start with you great my
heart is racing because it's a bit of a
theme with us to talk to actors about
their auditioning rock bottom thinking
back on your career is there a try out a
read or audition that you remember for
all the wrong reasons oh
yeah oh yeah um well actually this is
thematically on point um it begins in
the world of musical theater
and uh basically i auditioned for a
jagged little pill
i didn't know exactly what i was walking
into
and then i got there and there was like
you know the table of 12 people and like
the stage and they were like show us
what you've prepared
and so i started singing ironic
um
[Music]
you know okay ironic died the next day
yeah
and then i got to the chorus and i said
it's like rain
i forgot the chorus too ironic
and the irony was not lost on me
and uh that was really embarrassing well
you know what maybe cathartic to share
this story and it actually segues rather
nicely ben thinking back on all your
stage all your theater experience what's
the most jarring memory you have of
something going sideways in the middle
of a live show when i was in book of
mormon
the musical that i did in chicago and in
new york it was when i was doing it on
broadway there's a number at the end of
the first act called man up where my
character like who's been a nerd for the
whole show who remains a nerd basically
the whole show like finally kind of like
you know decides to go for it and become
the hero of the story and so it turns
into this like kind of comedy like rock
number and the whole thing opens with
this big knee slide down to the front of
the stage and i remember doing the slide
and just hearing like
and so basically my pants ripped from
like top of crotch to back
and so i was wearing like tidy whities
and chaps essentially for the rest of
the number um the nice thing about it is
that book of mormon's like really
ridiculous and absurd so i feel like
everybody kind of just went with it and
felt like it was part of the vibe but um
my junk was out on broadway
that's incredible
well there you have it turning the page
on round one and going into round two
probably gonna crank up the heat a
little bit here and ben will stay on you
you know you have you have a grammy an
emmy a tony i know that you'll tell me
that you put all of those
accomplishments on the same plane but if
you were asked to rank them on a bizarre
chicken wing talk show how would you put
those accomplishments in order from most
important to you to least you can also
include the time that you ripped a water
slide a hundred times in a single day on
a family vacation is one of your
accomplishments how did you know that um
the same guy who left the bottle of
liquor behind the dumpster behind mel's
diner before senior prom told me that
one what
teddy oh
oh my god
what's up teddy
um
wow okay well now i'm gonna answer it
just because of that okay i i think it's
gonna be worth it for me to just go for
this um speaking very specifically about
my experience with each of these letters
um i got to put the water slides first
because that's my greatest
accomplishment and you know my family
comes before everything
the the t is going to come first in the
letters because i'm a musical theater
boy i'm a broadway boy that's been my
dream since i was five years old to be
on broadway and win a tony it also
probably required the most like blood
sweat and tears in terms of doing that
show eight times a week
i'm gonna put that g next because it was
gonna put that
because it was uh the cast album that
i'm super proud of and i sang on on a
lot of those songs and so i did feel
like i put a lot of myself out there for
that um and then the e is going to come
up last but only because it was a
daytime e for a performance on the today
show and i got to do that with like 13
other cast members so it required the
least from me um so that's my order
w t
g
e
a man
we'll go to you now during an interview
going into your senior year of high
school you talked about having to juggle
s.a.t prep along with your role for the
nbc sitcom mr robinson
what was your sat
[Music]
score i that was very traumatic for me
so i definitely it's it's nowhere in
there it's not in my brain so i have to
eat one of these now i believe in you
whatever it's a wing it's like you're on
vacation you're getting some wings as an
apple someone has like
little specks on it i don't trust that
i'm going with this one i was honestly
gonna say the same thing i'm really glad
you did that
yeah that's right
[Music]
she's hot
she's hot
what you're eating going back
get in there
all right amanda we'll stay on you we'll
stay on you you know singers always use
the excuse about protecting their voice
they use it as an excuse for everything
including sometimes not doing hot ones
be honest be honest when's the last time
that you explained away a personal or
professional obligation with that
defense
i'm so distracted but
i think it's happening to me
right now
um
when was the last uh
i mean i don't know i'm not like a
broadway guy like this guy
i don't have to use my voice that often
i don't save it that often as somebody
though who now has a foot in both worlds
and what ways do uh broadway or stage
actors have to be handled with kid
gloves compared to screen actors
handled with kid gloves yeah how do we
three-handed with kid gloves
um
i mean
you guys literally do need to
rest your voices
like you actually and you're stronger
than us i don't know they're way
stronger and tougher than us
all right ben i know that show business
it runs in the blood yeah your father
he's a film tv theater producer who's
whose credits they include legally
blonde into the woods la la land mary
poppins returns the musical wicked with
that in mind from your perspective
what's the worst project your dad's ever
produced
can't wait to eat the swing
okay
i'm gonna do number two because that's
what you did all right joining the party
cheers love you love you dad
did you pick the same one as me okay
mm-hmm
yeah
okay
okay okay it feels nice now like my
entire mouth is numb and it's kind of
nice i'm looking forward to when it
transitions to that once it numbs
completely out there
yeah
ah okay whoo swim well the good news is
we'll move this forward here to another
round amandla yeah it's a banner year
for musicals you have oscar potential
from likes from dear evan hansen west
side story and in the heights pound for
pound though i'm curious which classical
musical do you think is the most
overrated and why ooh
okay
all right
yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay
this is like another fleck just went
into my throat like yeah i'm like
i got the next one
yeah sure still very much living that
first journey for me
okay
[Music]
no problem
careful don't tempt the fate like that
no problem
whoa
whoa i don't know what i'm looking at
but i'm
i surrender i surrender
maybe i'm just numb
yeah
or it'll time delay on you and kind of
drop and explode and grow
so never turn the page completely on
that
[Music]
is that what's happening
[Music]
all right
where do you find harsher critics movie
reviewers or theater buffs and then do
you have an example in your mind of of
an especially unfair criticism
okay
okay
i think musical theater critics are
harder because i think they have a
better [ __ ] meter like i think when
we love live performance in live theater
it's harder to pull one over on you
and i also think they get really
attached to the material when a musical
gets adapted to a film so they get
really critical something changes
um
i can think of a lot of different ways
in which that's been criticized i'm
trying to think of one in particular i
think like
um into the woods like you mentioned
before when that was adapted which i
think is a beautiful adaptation people
got really critical about certain songs
that were missing certain songs that
weren't there certain casting choices
um super harsh about that um
and uh yeah i stand by that
mike drop we have ben bring in the truth
amandla bring in the dab
dear evan hansen in theaters september
24th is there anything that you guys
want to say before you rush into an ice
bath
[Music]
my sinuses are clear i'll say that
let's clap to that
[Music]
it hears you tempting fate you know like
in and when you're watching like wwe
wrestling and uh somebody's showboating
that's when they get hit over the head
with a chair you know like when you when
you talk about you okay though yeah yeah
yeah we're coming out of it we're gonna
rally out of it yeah
this is gonna be awesome
i'm excited to watch it this was really
fun
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody shawn
evans here just wanted to say thank you
so much for watching today's episode and
it's happened the day has finally come
for the youtubes hot ones toy that's
right the u2's hot ones toy is available
at
shop.firstweekfeast.com that's
shop.firstnewfeast.com
to get your hands on the hot ones you
choose toy look at this got the table
got the sauces got the milk the wings on
deck
it's handsome if i do say so myself
[Music]